welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and birds of prey in the
fantabulous Emancipation of one harley
quinn does everything for DC that did
pulled it for the x-men maximum effort
dosage of vitamin r-rated violence free
spirit its awareness so let's go see my
scene through this movie to break down
the movies Easter eggs including a
post-credit moment business that's
really what it was it wasn't a scene it
was a moment spoilers ahead ok the film
opens with an animated sequence showing
a life of hard Lane Quinzel meeting the
Joker in Arkham Asylum now we don't get
a cameo by Jared Leto's Joker but there
is an animated form that looks a lot
like the cartoon Joker from the 1968
Adventures of Batman series the
animation also shows Harley stealing a
big diamond for Joker and Joker taking
the credit for shadowing the stolen
diamonds so central to this movie's plot
we then switch to live action with
Harley Quinn blade once more by Margot
Robbie returning from Suicide Squad
telling us about her recent breakup with
puddin she gets locked out of house set
photos actually revealed that we were
gonna see mr. J throw her stuff out of
an upstairs window but that part was cut
it's a super fun to see Harley work
through her depression here and actually
this week's episode of the big question
gives us a fascinating psychological
profile of the character be sure to
check it out I love that episode
Harley gets her hyena a nod to Harley's
eye a miss bud in lieu from Batman in
the animated series were named after
Abbott and Costello he or she names a
hyena Bruce after that hunka hunka Wayne
guy
Harley also does roller derby taken from
her 2013 comics storyline which Harley
moves to Coney Island start skating
Harley drinks her life away at the club
of romance I own his black mask played
by hello tha you and McGregor and the
comics black mask is a wealthy heir who
runs the pulse based society gang and he
wears a skull mask carved from the ebony
of his father's casket here his
right-hand man is Chris Messina as
Victor Zsasz Victor Zsasz is a DC serial
killer who carves his cars into a skin
for every victim that he kills sionis
and zazen this movie cut off people's
faces yeah including that of mr. Keogh
whose gold lions crime family would not
lets Ionis take over the first act also
introduces us to the other key players
like canary Dinah Lance played by jurnee
smollett Bell it stated that canary got
her boys from her mother a nod to the
fact that black canary has been around
for so long in the DC Comics originally
in 1947 that DC passed down the title
from mother to daughter
you may notice now Canaries high note
rattles whoa martini glass setting up
her big canary cry in the final act
detective Renee Montoya Rosie Perez
oversees a crime family of murdered
gangsters and then heads up
to the ACE chemical plant that's on fire
when hardly blew it up this ACE chemical
plant was the location she and Joker had
their first real date that acidified
Harley's skin and hair noticed how on
the gate is the word Janice Janice
cosmetics is a company owned by sy own
as his family and actually showed up as
an easter egg back in Justice League
remember that movie the one that no one
ever complained about seeing the
director's cut of anyway mojo his crime
scene was caused actually by Helena
Bertinelli mary elizabeth winstead as
the mysterious crossbow killer though
she prefers a title Huntress we learned
how her parents were murdered by a
character named Don Volante the
Galante's were actually one of the five
Gotham mob families in the comics this
opening act is all restructured out of
chronological order with Harley
repeatedly having a backup to catch us
up on events an interesting reflection
of the characters impatience and
motormouth actually always gets ahead of
herself loj Bosco plays a young
Cassandra Cain a pickpocket who makes
the mistake of swiping the bertinelli
diamond from zazz engraved deep in that
30 carat diamond is the codes to the
Bertinelli family's accounts in fortune
and of course Cass gobbles it to keep it
from being confiscated by the capstone
location you know seeing Harley Quinn
bounce through life with so much energy
and enthusiasm makes me super jealous
because you know after all the hours I
spend Reed watching movies breaking down
trailers it kind of wipes out my energy
so the way that I stay super alert as I
sit down to work for y'all is with bang
energy and thanks to bang for sponsoring
this video every can of bang is 16
ounces that's right there's no wimpy 12
ounce cans here it contains 300
milligrams of caffeine but it's
sugar-free and has zero calories yet it
tastes great
there's over 20 different flavors to
choose from and one of these grape
flavors is candy apple crisp you get
that candy apple but it's also crisp
it's right know crappy Red Delicious
we're talking really smith flavors in
here but like already wouldn't sip in
and I'm feeling the energy so you know
the mornings that I was up late the
night before writing the movie break
down and I was like dragging a trail of
slobber across the floor as someone was
dragging me to my office chair I can't a
bang energy like this helps pick me up
so that I can just like blast through
more work and see all the colors that
Harley Quinn sees yeah now I feel like
I'm in Gentlemen Prefer Blondes check
out bang on Instagram you can get 25%
off your order at bang energy calm when
you use the code new monster is 25 and
there you can get a variety 12-pack with
a dozen of their flavors flavors like
pina colada cotton candy birthday cake
bash and yeah candy apple crisp so all
my book today is gonna feel candy apple
like in crisp
thanks again to Bing energy for
sponsoring this video and get 25% off at
bang - energy calm using the code new
rock stars twenty five and eight
followed the inventor of bang on
instagram at bang energy dot CEO okay
back to the breakdown so once it becomes
known that Harley and the Joker are
broken up that removes Harley's immunity
leads to our capture and wince Iona's
hit sir Harley conceives or plan to try
to get the diamond back with a musical
homage to Marilyn Monroe's diamonds are
a girl's best friend from movie
Gentlemen Prefer Blondes it's also kind
of a fun parallel to you and McGregor's
character Moulin Rouge watching the cold
Kidman do this number
Harley breaks cast from jail and she's a
grenade launcher equipped with colored
smoke grenades and glitter bombs bang
bang is written on the barrel beside a
sticker with the Suicide Squad logo fun
Easter egg here she passes a wanted sign
it says hey and the picture is Captain
Boomerang Jai Courtney the fact that
he's wanted now suggests that he also
broke out of the maximum security prison
and Suicide Squad setting up his return
and James Gunn's upcoming sequel hardly
fight for the other mercenaries that
sionis has sent after cast and these
guys shoot up a pallet of cocaine in no
way the cops didn't dip into that and I
just love how Harley inhales it like
Popeye with spinach you can even see her
pupils dilating Harley's brain on drugs
is actually her breakfast sandwich also
in this evidence Locker so you could see
katana as a sword on one of the shelves
when he learns that Harley has betrayed
him and enraged Iona's puts on his
iconic mask now the penalty into the
background or a cool reflection of the
kind of kinky energy McGregor plays
Ionis with the bondage
elements one figure become the mascot
another figure as if to say my identity
comes from my passion to suffocate the
life out of others Hurley's crash pad
gets bombed seemingly killing her I mean
a Bruce and there are definitely
parallels to John wick here you know
with the dead pup revenge tale along
with the hill bill movies like there's a
moment Harley finds herself paralyzed
like the bride was and there's this big
mission to take down this controlling
man and both characters at one point
break the fourth wall from behind the
wheel Harley at one point mentions
Robinson Park a Gotham City landmark
that's named for a classic Batman artist
Jerry Robinson and later there's a TV
screen of Renee's apartment that shows
that she's watching a black-and-white
Harlequin film Harley has head to her
hideout at amusement Mile a location in
Gotham from the DC Comics that her and
the Joker had been seen around and all
the ladies in the film finally grouped
together in her booby trap funhouse on
one of the windows in this funhouse in
the background
you can see hahahahahah tagged all over
it suggesting that this place was a safe
house for her in the Joker Hunter shows
up and kills
zaz and as a Gerber war Renee finds a
shirt that Harley snatches back for its
sentimental value it's her daddy's
little monster shirt that she wore in
Suicide Squad and then after the fight
caskets taken canary performs her canary
cry the clear path for Harley to skate
after them she wrecks the cars and
pursues Iona's to cast two founders pure
which seems like a mash-up of Gotham
pier from the comics and founders Island
from Arkham games through the fog Harley
fires her one bullet at sionis but it's
actually a statue which is kind of setup
of the statue of himself that sionis had
miss sweet earlier but Kass takes care
of him by revealing that she stole
Harley's ring actually a grenade pin
which hilariously blows toyotas to bits
after the ladies get tacos and marks of
their Avengers swarm a moment and hardly
Kass and Bruce ride off in a stolen car
and behind them there's a sign for
personal injury lawyers fuller inform
perhaps a nod to Sondra fuller the
female Clayface who can shape-shift in
the new forms we also see the three
birds of prey united kicking ass with
Black Canary and some new wardrobe
including fishnet stockings which is a
nod to her iconic look from the comics
and that brings us to the film's
post-credit moment it was simply Harley
Quinn's boys speaking over the end
credits she says are you dummies still
sitting there fine since you stuck it
out so long I'll tell you a super-duper
secret secret but you can't tell anyone
okay did you know Batman and it cuts off
but the assumption is that hard
was going to reference the Harlequin
animated series on DC Universe where she
refers to Batman as a guy who bats why
are you protecting a psychotic clown or
treat you like garbage
the guy who bats eye I don't know how
that would be possible they're pretty
small anyway I don't want to picture it
comment down below with your favorite
moment from birds of prey follow me at a
boss follow new rock stars and social
media subscribe general rock stars here
on YouTube for breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching
[Music]